[Music]
they say the camera never lies that
might be true but that doesn't always
mean it tells us exactly what's going on
this video will show you some spooky odd
and downright mysterious things that we
can't fully explain and have been caught
on camera be sure to watch this video
until the end to hear about a strange
creature spotted in the Antarctic if
you've never visited the things before
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and hit the like button here are 5
unexplained mystery is caught on camera
something weird on a surveillance camera
most people who own surveillance cameras
don't want to see anyone unexpected on
the film that they take someone you
don't know turning up could mean trouble
and stress but for one family their CCTV
showed them an uninvited guest that they
just couldn't explain the Hernandez
family of Clovis New Mexico who are
having their family dinner one quiet
Thursday night in August 2017 when
something came up on camera but when
they had a look they were sure it wasn't
a person the only thing that could come
up with was that it was actually a ghost
householder Brianna Hernandez said that
she could see it 100% on the video
Brianna also said that the house had
some strange history a neighbor told her
that his uncle had passed away while
living in a house on the same site as
the families perhaps the vision that was
captured on the surveillance camera was
that very same uncle it's tricky to
figure out what else could have made
such an image on film it doesn't look a
bit too bright to be a regular person
and it's the wrong shape for some kind
of animal although we can't explain it
one thing is for certain
Brianna Hernandez now believes in ghosts
and is keeping her eye on her CCTV an
eye in the sky the weather can do some
pretty strange things for instance we've
all been in a situation where it's been
bright and sunny and then it starts
raining without there seeming to be any
rain clouds but we're not sure whether
this one can be put down to climate in
May 2017 Graham Telford of Leeds West
Yorkshire ruk who's taking photos of the
sky when he found what appeared to be an
eye in the clouds he took a photo and
even though he doesn't normally
leave in such things said he got the
feeling he was being watched it was a
cloudy day in the north of England but
we aren't entirely sure they were normal
clouds how else would you explain the
eye Graham's friend said they thought
the bizarre formation meant something
the eye is definitely there and it's
doing our heads in of course as some
people have suggested it could just be a
funny-looking cloud but other people
have said it could be something a lot
more sinister and yet more people have
said it might be some bizarre message
from the sinister Illuminati so we can't
quite be 100% sure what exactly it is
and what would make it appear where it
did this is pretty much unexplained
Bigfoot America's most mysterious being
The Legend of Bigfoot is one which has
kept people thinking for centuries now
the mysterious animal has never been
officially discovered by scientists
thought there have been hundreds of
sightings also known as sasquatch the
animal is said to look somewhere between
a bear and a gorilla it has reddish
brown fur and has been seen in forests
and mountains throughout North America
it is about eight feet tall and has a
strange and unpleasant smell it also has
very large feet up to 24 inches long
which is where it gets its name from for
such a rare creature it's certainly been
captured on film a lot but perhaps the
best record of Bigfoot that we have
comes from 2017 the video is taken by
the Dickson family on holiday and wild
horse lake in Oregon USA while a man is
speaking to the camera what appears to
be a Bigfoot
lumbers into view in the distance one of
the family members also asks what it is
they are told it might be a bear then
they ask why it would be up on its hind
legs frustratingly the animal is filmed
from some distance but it's certainly
unusual it doesn't really look like a
bear so we were wondering what it could
be
perhaps it is a sasquatch until someone
can prove otherwise what this creature
really is it's going to remain a mystery
Roswell first contact with aliens one of
the biggest questions that we don't know
the answer to is whether we're alone in
the universe although we haven't yet
found signs of intelligent life it's
possible that it's there but what about
an intelligent
that could build the technology that
could travel through space what if there
was a life-form that had already visited
earth in July 1947 near the town of
Roswell New Mexico a mysterious object
crash-landed into a ranch although the
authorities said it was a weather
balloon belief that we have been visited
by extraterrestrials persistent most
notably a picture claiming to be an
alien killed in the crash was released
in May 2015 the photo shows a figure
with a humanoid body and a large skull
although skeptics were quick to come
forward and call it a hoax there's still
some mystery researcher Anthony Borrelia
said he believed the creature in the
photo really was an alien he pointed out
that scientists had established the
picture was on genuine Kodak film dating
from 1947 and that they had not been
interfered with he said the only
conclusion was the humanoid was not a
deformed person mummy
dummy simian or dead servicemen it was
not a creature that finds its origin on
earth it was an alien we don't know
whether that's the case or not but we
don't know what else it is either
mysterious and Arctic creature this
picture is definitely chilling in more
ways than one it was taken in Antarctica
by someone on board a Japanese research
ship it's hard to tell what it is when
you first look at it the figure in the
picture resembles a pure white human
body only without a neck and with a head
at the top of the torso
what makes this picture even more spooky
is that the thing and it looks like a
description of a ninja if you don't know
what an engine is it's a creature that
has been spotted by people since the
1960s near the South Pole without ever
being completely documented they are
said to be completely white and up to 90
feet long reports say they have arms and
legs and usually appear at night
what makes this picture chilling is that
reports of ninjin were originally
dismissed as being of albino whales but
this photo shows a creature on two legs
it's obviously taken from some distance
but if it's not a mysterious ningen we
don't know what it is it looks to
well-put-together to be a random lump of
ice and we don't know what other
creature it could be of
errantly people who have spotted ningen
which means human in japanese have been
told by the Tokyo authorities to keep
quiet about it we don't know if that's
true but we would love to know what the
thing in this photo is let us know in
the comments and that's all for our five
unexplained mysteries caught on camera
if you like it why not watch 10 amazing
discoveries that rewrote history thanks
for watching
[Music]